the March began in the southern French
border city of on-die thousands of
protesters including some from the
yellow fest movement walked to Spain to
demonstrate against the g7 summit in
Biarritz protesters say global leaders
and their capitalist policies are
responsible for many of the world's
problems
it's just flagrant Apocrypha that the
theme of the summit is the fight against
inequality when it's them who are the
source of all inequality and inequality
is increasing because of them it's a
fast sheer provocation although
thousands of police have been deployed
to guard against violence during the
summit officers of the protest kept a
low profile French and Spanish
authorities have allowed this protest on
the border because it is 12 kilometers
south of periods the upscale resort
where g7 leaders are beginning their
summit the idea is to keep the
demonstrators as far away as possible
from the international meeting one of
the main issues at the g7 will be
climate change but few people at the
protest believe there would be progress
some said the fires burning in the
Amazon rainforest were yet another
example of politicians failing to
protect the planet they're obviously not
interested in climate there are lots of
nice promises but they rarely keep them
they're not conscious that today is the
big emergency we're on the edge but we
just keep going the French president
who's hosting the summit wants France to
take the global lead on climate and he's
called for emergency talks on the Amazon
regarding the Amazon we will not only
launch it called but also actions from
all the world powers present here and in
partnership with Amazon countries for
investment their first to fight all
these fires but also to help Brazil and
other countries affect most protesters
say they're fed up with what they regard
as elite politicians who are out of
touch with the lives of ordinary people
the image of leaders from the world's
richest countries getting down to
business and a luxury hotel in periods
is unlikely to change their opinion
Natasha Butler al Jazeera on the
Spanish border